تجددت في الخرطوم التضاهرات التي تطالب
بحكم مدني كامل في السودان كما تاتي هذه
التظاهره في ذكرى احتجاجات ال17 من نوفمبر
والتي قتل فيها 15 متظاهرا متابعا
[موسيقى]
كيف الحال
وفي المقابل قلم وفوض الامم المتحده
الحقوق الانسان فولكرتونورك قال انه يجب
على جميع الاطراف العمليه السياسيه دعمها
في السودان وتقديم تنازلات وتغليف مصلحه
البلاد شدد ايضا على ضروره التوصل الى
توافق وطن الشامل يسهم في تحقيق مصلحه
السودان على المستويين المحلي وايضا
الدولي مشيرا الى انه يتضامن مع
السودانيين الذين يطالبون بتحقيق تطلعاتهم
نحو الوصول الى المستقبل
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
محمد عثمان اهلا بك محمد انقل لنا المشهد
من عندك او حجم هذه التظاهرات والشعارات
الرئيسيه المرفوعه
هذا المشهد بدا منذ الساعه الواحده بتوقيت
الخرطوم حيث بعد تنسيقيات لجانا المقاومه
هنا في منطقه الخرطوم بحري الى هذه
التظاهره الى هذه النقطه تحديدا شارع
المؤسسه في منطقه الخرطوم بحري وفي ذلك
دلاله ورساله مهمه همم من تنسيقيات لجانا
المقاومه وهو احياء ذكرى مجزره السابع عشر
من نوفمبر هذا اليوم الذي له يعني دلاله
كبيره لدى المتظاهرين حيث يعني تم في هذا
همم
يعني همم الاعتداء على المتظاهرين مما ادى
الى وفاه 15 من الشباب
والشابات في هذا اليوم ايضا كانوا همم
المتظاهرين كانوا قد دخلوا الى محيط القصر
الرئاسي وذلك في العام السابق وبالتالي
هذا اليوم له دلاله كبيره واهميه همم
كبيره الرساله اخرى التي فهمت من هذه
التظاهره اليوم انها الرساله ل- اا المكون
العسكري والمكون المدني همم هذه الرساله
هي تحمل الرفض اا تنسيقيات لجانا المقاومه
لما سمي
بالتفاهمات ما بين المكون العسكري والمجلس
المركزي لقوى الحريه والتغيير والتي تم
الاعلان عنها يعني في المؤتمر الصحفي مساء
الامس لجان المقاومه هي ما زالت تتمسك
بلائتها الثلاثه لا تفاوض لا شراكه ولا
شرعيه وبالتالي هي ترى بان
التمسك بخيارات الشارع والتمسك ايضا
بانهاء ما سمي همم انقلاب الخامس والعشرين
من اكتوبر يجب ان يتم وفق رؤيه لجان
المقاومه للعمليه السياسيه وليست رؤيه
المجلس المركزي لقوه الحريه والتغيير او
حتى المكونات المدنيه
لهم مرضا التصريح المتعلق بانه
توقيع اي اتفاق دون اشراق الجميع او لا
نعم هي تعتبر بان مساله تاجيل يعني كل
المطالبات التي دفع بها الشارع ودفعت بها
تنسيقيات لجانا المقاومه خاصه المتعلقه
باسر الضحايا المتعلقه بالانتهاكات التي
تمت للمتظاهرين في الشارع هم يعتبرون ان
تاجيل هذا الملف والملف المهم الى مرحله
التفاوض لاحقا يعتبر في حد ذاته خيانه
لخيارات الشارع وبالتالي يعني تنسيقيات
لجانا المقاومه هي تتمسك بكل المطالب التي
دفعت بها لكافه النخب السياسيه بضروره
انجاز ملف العداله والعداله الانتقاليه
وازاله ايضا اثار نظام البشير وكذلك عدد
من المطالب التي ما تزال متمسكه بها
تنسيقيات لجان المقاومه
حجم الاقبال همم طبيعه من لديه الكلمه
النهائيه بهذا الاطار او صعب تحديد ذلك
لانه في ذكرى ايضا اساسيه في هذه
التظاهرات وبالتالي لا يمكن لنا ان نفصل
من هو مع علاءات الثلاث ومن هو فقط موجود
لاحياء هذه الذكره
نعم المجموعه التي دعت لهذه التظاهره
تحديدا هي مجموعه تتمسك باللائات الثلاث
ان لا تفاوض لا شراكه لا شرعيه ولكن ما
ذكرته صحيح ميسون باننا يعني بيتنا نشاهد
مشهد منقسم على نفسه بطبيعه الحال هنالك
تنسيقيات تتبع لجانا المقاومه هي منسوبه
لبعض الاحزاب السياسيه وهنالك من هو همم
غير محزب ولا ينتمي لاي حزب سياسي فقط
ينتمي للقضايا التي من اجلها خرج منذ يعني
2000 2018 ضد النظام المخلوع عمر البشير
وما زال متمسكا بكل هذه القضايا ما ذكرته
صحيح هنالك لجام مقاومه تتبع لاحزاب
سياسيه تنادي بمطالب محدده هي تدعم
بالمناسبه هذه التسويه وتقول ان فيها مخرج
الازمه السياسيه اما الجانب الاخر يرفض
تماما هذه همم التسويه يرفض
اللجوء همم لمساله الخيار مع الجلوس مع
المكون العسكري وبالتالي هو يرى في ان اا
قضاياه ومطالبه ما زالت لم تتحقق حتى الان
وهو من يتكفل وسينجز همم مساله تحقيق هذه
المطالب العربيه محمد عثمان شكرا جزيلا لك